cherry is reacting to being fired from
Sports Net after his divisive comments
on Saturday night Coach's Corner about
people not wearing poppies to honor
Remembrance Day let's start with that
you know I was talking to a veteran I
said I'm not gonna run the poppy thing
anymore because what's the sense I live
in Mississauga nobody wears a very few
people wear pop poppy the downtown
Toronto forget it downtown Toronto
nobody wears the poppy and I'm not gonna
be he says wait a minute how about
running it for the people that buy them
now you go to the small cities and you
know you know those the roles unrolls
you people love you you they come here
whatever it is you love our way of life
you love our milk and honey at least you
could pay a couple of bucks for poppies
or something like that these guys pay
for your way of life that you enjoy in
Canada these guys paid the the biggest
price hmm
yeah that quickly went viral Saturday
night and Sunday morning by midday
Sunday Sports Net issued a statement
condoning Don's you people who come to
this country rant and they said they
spoke to him now whose co-host Ron
MacLean had this to say the next night
on hometown hockey no I'm sure he made
the remarks which were hurtful
discriminatory which were flat-out wrong
we at Sports Net have apologized
it certainly doesn't stand for what
Sports Net or Rodgers represents we know
diversity as the strength of the country
we see it in the travels with our show
and with Hockey Night in Canada so I owe
you an apology too that's the big thing
that I want to emphasize i sat there I
did not catch it did not respond
Katherine Denise it's not a First Nation
once said in any wrongdoing the the real
key is recognition and acknowledgement
and I wanted to let you know that first
and then you work on the relationship so
that it isn't the visit so that
something can be a unifying event idle
no more was a great lesson to all of us
last night was a really great lesson but
Don and me we were wrong and I sincerely
apologize and I wanted to thank you for
calling me and Don on that class
hmm okay so the outrage didn't let up
nor did the call for Don to be fired so
on Monday Sports Net respondent and
fired Don they said following further
discussions with Don Cherry after
Saturday night's broadcast has been
decided is the right time for him to
immediately step down during the
broadcast he made divisive remarks but
do not represent our values or what we
stand for
yeah and in an interview with justice 90
to 5 with might show the rasa mocha show
he confirmed that Sports Net did give
him the chance to make an on-air apology
but he had no interest in doing that and
then he tried to explain his you people
reference makes no sense at all I say if
you if you see what I said I did not say
immigrants I did not say what I said was
everybody and I meant everybody whether
scotch-irish
English or anything everybody that comes
to this country should honor our fallen
dead and somehow or other it's been
misinterpreted and and this is what
happens
did did Ron MacLean throw you under the
bus with his apology at all no I I don't
want to get into Ron Ron MacLean he has
to do what he has to do and I have to do
what I have to do Mary don't go too long
so he did say another any of you had he
was disappointed sure now I'm clean Jan
says I'm with Don Cherry 100%
I insist we'll cancel culture is a
scourge on our society Paula says he
wasn't referring to all immigrants just
ones who don't wear one well he he was
just referring to immigrants he wasn't
talking about white people and very much
is his wording that he used was you like
our way of life like it's not your way
of life it's our way of life they just
say people who come to here so you're
definitely free to immigrants and that
kind of sense well it's not ears is that
it's not that he's referring to
non-white immigrants it's that he when
he said you people when you walk around
and you look at people not wearing
poppies what he's saying is that the
people that I see that I can make a
calculated sort of estimation that they
are immigrants they would not be white
people right because how would you know
so he's specifically talking about
non-white people right there's
definitely I mean there's no cover up
that you can do after that point right
and definitely I mean he says there's no
one that wears
Papi's intent on stronger absolutely is
a lot of people who are I'm every year I
always notice it to make sure that
people start there's a lot of young
people to wear it but sure there's a lot
of white people that aren't wearing
Papi's as well so I think maybe there is
initiative overall issue but I can't
like go along without even that's
immigrants aren't worries especially
when you have a lot of immigrants who
are refugees that are coming from
countries that are war-torn countries to
present the idea they don't know what it
means to sacrifice an award no but say
they may not know what it means to honor
the people who fought in this war yeah
but you don't know that no no this is it
so this one say I'm saying the farther
we get away from World War One at World
War two to hear the stories firsthand of
of people this sort of less impactful
those stories are and the less educated
we all get and there's there's a lot of
you know sort of younger people and and
I'm not going to say you people but I'm
talking about younger people who have
grown up with wars in Afghanistan and
Iraq that were built on lies and were
built on falsehoods and were part of the
us's nation build all this stuff you see
on television and so their view of war
is very different there's a generation
of people who are very anti-war and are
pacifists and they may look at all wars
the same and they may not be able to
separate what they've grown up with with
what went on in World War one a tent or
two and so that's another problem
there's all sorts of problems that are
going on but you can't take back what
you said and when you say something that
can get you fired you get fired yeah it
was time for him to go